by the way for all of y'all out there
that was like oh man the Lakers lost and
Draymond won't do a podcast like I
played for the Golden State Warriors
some of you people are so pathetic and
like the beliefs you allow yourself to
believe and I can absolutely understand
while life don't be so great because the
beliefs that you allow like to enter
your mind about someone else really is a
reflection of what you believe and think
of yourself and like how you operate in
things so I thought that was a very
interesting thing that people were like
oh man they lost them like Draymond
don't want to talk he's hurt like what
but actually I'm on vacation and um
having a margarita so cheers